Richard Feynman worked on the Manhattan
Project that built the atomic bomb he
uncovered what caused the space shuttle
Challenger disaster when no one else
could he won a Nobel Prize in physics he
accomplished all this with an IQ of 125.
you might think that's a pretty high IQ
considering the standard is a hundred
however one in 20 people has that IQ and
it isn't high enough to make it into
Mensa which accepts only the top two
percent usually a score of 132 or higher
I was an ordinary person who'd studied
High there's no Miracle people he didn't
see himself as anything special as he
said in this BBC interview but what set
him apart was his curiosity
growing up in Far Rockaway a
neighborhood in Queens New York his dad
encouraged him to learn how things
worked young Richard had a knack for
fixing radios his father expected him to
become a scientist his sister Joan
followed the same path Richard gained a
sense of humor from his mum he was a
real character and it showed now I'm
going to discuss how he would look for a
new law
in general we look for new law by the
following process first we guess it
then we come well don't laugh that's
really true Feynman seriously considered
becoming a mathematician but felt the
discipline was too abstract and
eventually switched to physics he
applied to Columbia University but was
rejected Colombia had a discriminatory
policy limiting the number of Jewish
students it admitted he enrolled at MIT
and graduated with a bachelor's degree
in 1939. he received a scholarship to
Princeton for grad studies on the
condition that he remained unmarried the
stipulation may have been intended to
ensure he fully focused on his studies
he did become engaged to his high school
sweetheart Arlene Greenbaum but they
didn't have long together
she was diagnosed with tuberculosis an
incurable disease at the time they
married on a ferry between New York and
New Jersey in 1942 before Arlene went
straight to another hospital she died
three years later exactly one month
before the U.S detonated the world's
first nuclear weapon the U.S feared that
Nazi Germany might develop a nuclear
weapon ahead of them so the Americans
raced to develop the atomic bomb first
the best and brightest scientists signed
up for the Manhattan Project where they
worked out of a secret Research Center
in Los Alamos New Mexico physicist
Robert Wilson encouraged fine men to
join the Manhattan Project as he had a
reputation for being exceptionally
gifted at math and physics he agreed and
moved his sweetheart to a hospital in
Albuquerque New Mexico where he could
visit her on weekends his work on the
project included calculating the energy
released from the detonation of a bomb
he and signed his Tans beta produced a
formula used to determine the energy
yield of a nuclear explosive beta used
to poke fun at fodmin's New York accent
thinking it made him sound like a bum
during his downtime at Los Alamos there
wasn't much to Muse himself with so
feidman fiddled around with picking
locks and cracking safes that contained
the bomb Project's secret documents the
documents were originally kept in filing
cabinets with padlocks which Feynman
wrote in his Memoir were as easy as pie
to open
cabinets with combination locks were
later installed but he figured out how
to crack those too once when he visited
the plant at Oak Ridge Tennessee that
processed uranium ore to be used in the
bomb managers gathered to discuss a
secret report but the executive who had
the document stored in a safe couldn't
access it because he didn't know the
combination and his secretary was away
Feynman fiddled around with a safe and
in 10 minutes I'd opened the safe that
contains all the secret documents about
the plant they were astonished the
Manhattan Project left a lasting mark on
feinman's Legacy even though he only
played a junior role because he had a
hand introducing the deadliest weapon
known to humankind the head of the
Manhattan Project Robert Oppenheimer was
also aggrieved by what scientists had
Unleashed on the world I told of his
Despair and downfall in another video
which I've Linked In My description
Feynman witnessed the detonation while
sitting in a truck parked about 20 miles
away he claimed to be the only person to
watch the Trinity test without wearing
glasses or goggles because he figured
that the truck's windshield would
protect him from the harmful ultraviolet
radiation nonetheless at the last moment
he ducked on the truck's floor as he saw
a tremendous flash of light in the sky
after leaving the Manhattan Project he
was no longer exempt from the draft but
he avoided compulsory military service
when he was judged to be mentally
incompetent
an army psychiatrist who assessed
Feynman wrote these words thanks people
talk about him thinks people stare at
him auditory hypnagogic hallucinations
talks to self talks to deceased wife
maternal aunt in mental institution very
peculiar stare
funman said most people laughed when he
told them the story but he wasn't very
amused and said it was all just a
misunderstanding instead of enlisting
Feynman accepted a teaching position at
Cornell University for four thousand
dollars a year he wasn't particularly
motivated there and was surprised when
he got offers to teach at UCLA UC
Berkeley and the renowned Institute for
advanced study in Princeton New Jersey
but he remained at Cornell and decided
to develop a new attitude why not just
enjoy physics and that's when his
curiosity about the world kicked in one
day when he was sitting in the cafeteria
at Cornell he noticed someone tossing a
plate in the air
he noticed that the Plate's motion was
similar to how tiny particles move and
interact with each other in the way that
the plate was affected by gravity and
air resistance tiny particles were also
affected by different forces
this helped him better understand
Quantum electrodynamics or QED a theory
that explains how atoms in light
interact with each other through the
electromagnetic force imagine a baseball
game where the baseball represents a
subatomic particle and the players
represent the force that acts on the
ball Fineman produced mathematical
equations that are like the rules of the
game they explain how the baseball or
particles are affected by the players or
force and how they interact with each
other he created diagrams that were very
helpful for scientists in understanding
and calculating these interactions his
curious nature allowed him to draw
connections between seemingly unrelated
things between a plate and subatomic
particles for his work in Quantum
electrodynamics he won the Nobel Prize
in physics in 1965. he shared the prize
with two other scientists who found
their own methods for the same problem
independently many believed he could
have won the Nobel Prize eyes again when
he and physicist Murray Gelman came up
with a theory that explained the weak
Force which makes certain atoms change
and give off energy they found that tiny
particles called neutrinos carry the
weak force and make the atoms change
it's like a game of pool where the
neutrinos are the cue ball that hits the
other balls or atoms and makes them move
he never really put down Roots at
Cornell he moved from student residences
to guest houses to squatting with
friends he reportedly liked to date
undergrads higher prostitutes and sleep
with the wives of his friends he also
didn't appreciate the weather in Upstate
New York and decided to trade the cold
slushy Winters for sunny weather by
moving to the West Coast to teach
physics at the California Institute of
Technology in 1950 where he remained
until his death
before heading to Caltech he spent a
year on sabbatical in Brazil where he
taught physics at a research center in
Rio de Janeiro he learned to speak
Portuguese
he played the Brazilian instrument for
jadera which is based on a frying pan
he loved playing instruments and also
took up The Bongo and conga drums Upon
returning to America he devoted himself
to revamping caltech's physics
curriculum for freshmen he and two other
professors transcribed their lectures
and turned them into a set of textbooks
that went on to sell more than a million
copies in English during his early years
at Caltech he also provided a
mathematical theory that explains the
strange behavior of liquid helium at
extremely low temperatures when liquid
helium comes close to absolute zero or
-273 degrees Celsius it turns into a
superfluid that does the impossible
leaking through this container he also
studied how electrons behave when they
Collide at very high speed he found they
act like marbles colliding in which they
can change direction and velocity this
helped scientists make new discoveries
in the field of high energy physics
his work was like a brush stroke on
canvas creating a masterpiece of
scientific understanding he also loved
art and took courses in painting and
drawing and became really good at
Portrait sketching he signed his works
with a pen name ophi as he wanted the
art to speak for itself rather than have
people think it was the work of a famous
physicist
he wasn't only interested in how things
looked on the outside but the beauty
that lay beneath the surface this is the
incredible way he described a flower to
the BBC I have a friend who's an artist
you hold up a flower and say look how
beautiful it is and I'll agree
CSI as an artist can see how beautiful
this is but you as a scientist oh take
this all apart and it becomes dull thing
and I think that he's kind of nutty I
see much more about the flower than he
sees I could imagine the cells in there
the complicated actions inside which
also have a beauty
the fact that the colors and the flower
evolved in order to attract insects to
pollinate it is interesting it means
that insects can see the color
it adds a question is this aesthetic
sense also exists in a lot of forms that
does it why is it aesthetic all kinds of
interesting questions
which the science knowledge only adds to
the excitement and mystery in the aura
of a flower it only adds I don't
understand how it subtracts
he loved to ask questions and think
outside the box that led him to get to
the bottom of what caused the Challenger
explosion in 1986 that killed the Seven
astronauts on board
feidman was already well respected in
the scientific Community but it was his
investigation of Challenger that made
him famous to the general public at
first he was hesitant to join the
commission tasked with investigating the
disaster because he preferred to stay
out of anything political but his third
wife Gwyneth reminded him of his
usefulness because he didn't do things
the conventional way maybe he'd spot
something others couldn't she was right
he realized that NASA and its
contractors tended to discourage their
own employees from criticizing
legitimate safety issues he saw the same
type of thing in Los Alamos involving
the security of those top secret
documents engineers at the firm NASA
contracted to make the rocket boosters
were concerned that the rubber gaskets
that sealed the boosters would fail in
cold weather however there is pressure
from NASA so the launch went ahead
anyway Feynman suspected that rubber
gaskets sealing the rocket boosters
called O-rings couldn't expand quickly
enough in cold weather to fully seal the
joints and failed to stop gas from
escaping leading to the catastrophe to
test his theory he dunked some rubber
O-rings into a glass of ice water on
live TV and I discovered that when you
put some pressure on it for a while and
then undo it it maintains it doesn't
stretch back it stays the same dimension
in other words
for a few seconds at least and more
seconds than that there's no resilience
in this particular material when it's at
a temperature of 32 degrees
I believe that has some significance
for our problem by the time of the
hearing cancer had weakened Feynman a
decade before he was diagnosed with
abdominal cancer that formed a massive
tumor on his abdomen which crushed one
of his kidneys and his spleen surgery
removed the tumor but he never fully
recovered near the end of his life he
tried to visit tuva a remote region in
southern Siberia bordering Mongolia That
Was Then part of the Soviet Union he
wanted to learn about a place he knew
nothing about but bureaucratic red tape
prevented him from traveling there he
died before his Visa arrived
Richard Feynman passed away on February
15 1988 at the age of 69.
in 2009 his daughter Michelle made the
journey to tuva to carry out his dream
shortly before he died the Los Angeles
Times interviewed Richard and asked what
he was most proud of he replied that I
was able to love my first wife with as
deep a love as I was able to
after Arlene died he wrote her letters
expressing his heartbreak I find it hard
to understand in my mind what it means
to love you after you are dead but I
still want to comfort and take care of
you and I want you to love me and care
for me
I loved you in so many ways so much and
now it is clearly even more true you can
give me nothing now yet I love you so
that you stand in my way of loving
anyone else but I want you to stand
there you dead are so much better than
anyone else alive
P.S please excuse my not mailing this
but I don't know your new address
while fine men may have believed that
his love for his wife was his greatest
achievement to the world his passion and
Devotion to science was incomparable yet
he insisted he was nothing special
there's no Talent or special Miracle
ability to understand quantum mechanics
or Miracle ability
to imagine electromagnetic fields that
comes without practice and reading and
learning and study so if you say you
take an ordinary person who's willing to
devote a great deal of time and study
and work and thinking and Mathematics
and timeline then he's become a
scientist who knows if he would have
scored higher had he taken another IQ
test in school regardless he was
undoubtedly a genius thanks to his
Perpetual curiosity to learn why things
work the way they do
if you're curious just like vodmin and
want to learn about why things work the
way they do
brilliant.org is a free website and app
where you can learn math science and
computer science interactively my
viewers especially love their scientific
thinking course where instead of
learning scientific principles in an
abstract way you get to learn through
physical Insight like trying to figure
out how to make this bridge as rigid as
possible with as few beams as possible
or at what temperature the heat should
be turned to to maintain 100 degrees
Celsius
Brilliance computer science courses are
also really popular with my viewers and
no previous coding experience is
necessary I personally like to go
through the logic courses to improve my
critical thinking skills brilliant is
great if you're a student or if you're
already in the workforce and want to
brush up on what you already know if you
ever get stuck you can click on show
explanation to see where you went wrong
brilliant is free to try out if you head
to brilliant.org newsthink my custom
link is in my description and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off Brilliance annual premium
subscription which gives you access to
all of the offerings